Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab and today
we're talking about color. Okay.
And that actually brings
us back to Jane Nights.
I'm a professor of Ophthalmology,
university of Washington, Seattle.
Jay has actually spent his entire career
trying to get creatures to see colors
that they normally can't see.
Well, yeah. And he started,
this is kind of an interesting story,
a by taking some colorblind monkeys who
couldn't see red. They have blue cones,
green cones, but no red cones, which
is not unlike a lot of human males.
In any case,
he had these monkeys and was able to take
the human gene for the red cone rabbit
and a virus injected into
the monkey's eyes and Bam,
the monkeys suddenly had red
cones. Yeah. So it had blue,
green, and red. Was this like
Lasik? So it was just like a,
a 10 minute outpatient situation
for the monkeys. I would say close,
close to Lasik. Could they
then now see red? Well,
every single morning before
they get their breakfast,
they have to do their
color vision test. So,
so we'd say each monkey at a computer,
we add a touch screen and the
screen looks totally gray, man.
We bought that field of gray.
He adds a little red blob
right now. Here's the key.
We use grape juice as the reinforcement
for the monkeys. But the game is, yeah,
the touch the blob before you get
your juice. So before the surgery,
they weren't seeing any blobs and they
weren't getting any juice because all
they could see was gray.
So a little red block could be right
there in front of them and they never see
it. And the morning after, they're
a lasix color booster shot. Okay,
that's true. Did you see it? They
still couldn't see it.
Day after day they would do their
tests and everyday they would fail.
Every day they would fail
and
no blob, no juice. But it's fun for them.
They get out of their cage and
they talk to their friends.
And then did you fail? Fail. Okay.
You got up the other day, another fail
until one morning after about 20 weeks,
Jay woke up the monkeys gave them
the test and they began to not fail.
Really, if you watched the video of this,
it actually looks like the
monkey is like, wow, you know,
I'm not having any failures and check
out this dot. Look at this thing.
Check it out.
But I did get some sense that they
felt like that their life had improved.
[inaudible] well, if this
works so well with the monkeys,
couldn't you take a colorblind human
and give them back the thing they're
missing? Absolutely.
We could cure colorblindness in a
human with exactly this technique.
We really,
the only thing that we have to do is
convince the FDA that the risks are low
enough and the benefit is high enough
that it'd be something we could do and
have never tried it or
no, we've never tried it.
Although I get a lot of emails that
say I don't care what the risks are.
I've even had offers.
How bout if I come to your laboratory
and you don't tell anybody late at night
and you give me the shot in the
eye and we won't tell anyone,
which brings us back to
our original question.
If you can take a colorblind human
and give them normal color vision,
could you take a normal color seer and
boost them to make them a little more
shrimpy? Well, yes. Yeah.
We said, sure, why not. But then
there's the whole FDA thing.
But here's the real surprise.
J says there were some people who are
already a little bit mantis shrimp,
like there are colored mutants,
if I may call them that in the nicest
possible way among us or they're out there
in theory.
Okay, so here's the deal. The genes
for the cones in our eyes see color.
You have the red queen blue cones. Yep.
They're on the x chromosome. Now men,
as we know, only have one of those
women have two x chromosomes,
which means that women have two
sets of these cone making genes.
Normally one said it's just
a spare. It's not used,
but still they've got two
sets. And so someone said, Aha,
it is theoretically
possible. Then some women,
this spare set of jeans
might mix up, turn on,
morph into a whole new cone, a forth comb.
We're going to call it the yellow cone.
So people with normal color vision are
trichromatic cause we've got three cones.
A woman like that would
be a tetra Chromat.
So altogether she'd have a blue
cone, a green cone, a yellow cone,
and a red count, but she
wouldn't just see more yellow.
This new yellow would mix with the red
and the blue and the green to create
thousands, maybe millions
of more shades of color.
This amazing technicolor
is not the right word.
It's whatever would be
the DEX kind of color.
That would be even more super duper.
This was just the thought experiment.
Yeah, but Jay actually figured
out a way to test for this.
We can look in people's blood and I can
say this woman has the genes for blue
cones, green cons, yellow
cones, red cones. You can
do a DNA test. Really? Yeah.
So he started doing blood tests
and he found this one woman,
she worked at the same place we did
crazily enough at the university.
He looked at her DNA and he saw
the gene for the fourth coat.
Yeah. Wow.
So did she see in super technicolor
or how would you even know that was,
that was a problem.
And so we thought of an experiment in
order to be able to see whether or not she
had this extra dimension of Color Vision.
He was able to produce these two
yellow lights that to us, you know,
trichromatic normal track
Crummins look totally identical.
We're color blind to that
difference. But to a Tetra Chromat,
a woman with this fourth cone, they
would look totally different. Yeah.
So they brought her in.
I said, okay, here it is.
Do you see these as different?
And she said, no, no,
I don't see them as any to know,
but the story doesn't end there. Good.
Jay told us about a colleague of his
in England because she's at New Castle
named Gabrielle Jordan,
and she apparently found eight of
these women with the extra cone.
And out of those eight,
seven of those women behave exactly like
the person that I had tested couldn't
see the difference,
but one of them took one look at
those two yellows and said no,
they look totally different to me.
Oh, one of these women was saw.
The south side is different.
So one of them had the Koan but you could
use it and the others had the cone but
couldn't use it or yup.
So why is that? Yeah, why?
Well this is the part if you'd like,
I could tell you what my theory
is of what's going on. Yeah,
so I think that right,
Jace has,
let's just imagine you grew up in a world
without color completely and totally a
black and white world houses would be
painted black and white printers with all
the print in black and white. Even the TV,
they would just have black and white TV.
Women's makeup would be just, you know,
either dark or light.
So it wouldn't make any difference if
you had color vision because you would
never use that color vision.
There'd be no words for color.
[inaudible]
now, just to make an interesting,
let's imagine one day a bright
red apple plops into your world.
How would you react to it?
What'd you see it you think, well,
so that's a very good question.
Maybe says j. Even though you have
the ability to see that Red Apple,
if you've never had a chance to
use that ability to practice,
it may just lay dormant and that he thinks
might be what happens to women living
with the extra cone in our world.
They're very rarely subjected to colors
that would stimulate their extra kind of
cone differently.
So you're saying those other colors just
aren't around enough for them? Yeah.
Everything that we make is based on
the fact that humans are trichromatic.
The television only has three colors.
Our color printers have
three different colors.
There's nothing out there that we make
artificially that a tetra chromatic could
see.
But Jay says maybe some women because
they're just more aware or because of the
job that they do. Maybe someone
who works with color all the time,
like a florist or a
painter, little by little
because they're paying
such close attention,
their brain would learn
to see that difference.
[inaudible]
so naturally we wanted to find one of
these mythic labels in that mythic.
Maybe I say
that as it,
cause we tried to find that one woman
that he mentioned you the one out of
eight.
Yeah. And we had a really hard time and
we began to doubt that she even existed.
And then we began to look online and
you see all these websites thing,
are you a tetra Chromat
contact us, contact us.
Everybody is searching for these women.
And we began to feel like you were
chasing Unicorns a little bit.
But then our producer Tim Howard claimed,
he claimed that he had
found one calculating. Yeah,
you are right on the parish street.
He'd been in touch with j j
told him that he tested a woman,
determined that she had the fourth cone
and this woman was an interior designer.
Oh. But Jay had not yet determined
whether she could use her fourth cone.
So we sent Tim to
Pittsburgh where she lives
right there to see what he could
find out. Hi, I'm Susan Hogan.
There are three and an
interior designer. Lucia,
like she's great or you
have a jukebox. Really?
You want me to play something?
How about number three? Oh seven.
It just seems appropriate cause it's
about color. Wider shade of Pam.
Um, she told me a lot about
how she uses color in her work.
You see the different colors of paint
because she thinks a lot about it in terms
of painting walls. I know the way
the sun is oriented in a room,
each wall will look a different color
even though in any case, here's my plan.
I ordered this test before
I went to Pittsburgh that
Jay had suggested I get at.
Okay. Alright. Open it, open it up.
It involved these little
pieces of brown fabric. Okay.
They all look identical. They
look strikingly the same to me.
Yeah. Lynn, Brenna, me, Soren. Those
are completely indistinguishable.
Couldn't see a difference. They
all look the same to you guys. Yes,
but I'm assuming they're actually not
all the same. That's the trick. Jay said,
if you show them to a real tetra Chromat,
they're going to be able to see these
subtle differences that you know,
you and I can't see.
And I'm back to Pittsburgh. So how about
we head over toward that tree? Is that,
that looked good. Take my shoes off.
Oh yeah. It'll be much more fun for me.
We ended up doing the test in a nearby
park. We're going to do a bunch of these,
if you don't mind. The first trial
I took out three of the swatches,
two that were exactly the same and
one that was supposedly different.
And when you took it out, could you
see the difference? No. No. Huh.
So I go behind the tree
and I whisper into the mic.
Number three is different. Number
three, I hope you couldn't hear me.
Yeah, I'll let you take a look.
She steps back in the swatches,
gives a look for a moment and then she
says number three said third one is
different. It's more neutral, less
red than one and two on the left.
One for one luck. So I went
behind the tree eye on second,
changed up the swatches so that now the
middle swatch was the odd one out and
same, same deal. Ready, set, go easy.
Which number? It looks different.
The middle middling number two.
You are right? Yeah. Wow. Okay.
Then I figured I got to make it
harder. I switched it up and I made it.
So all three are different
and I didn't tell her,
oh three are different.
[inaudible]
all three different I o green,
red less red as I'm knocking
it out of the park. I didn't,
I do as well on my sats.
Tim. Wow. You found her.
I was sure that she was not going to
be, there's no way this test can work.
Well, it actually might not
have totally worked. Right.
What did she start to fail there? There's
one little thing I didn't mention,
but I brought along a friend, um,
Jason Lacroix, painter landscape,
still life thought. I try him out as
a control cause you were thinking, uh,
let's get someone who likes color but
as a boy and can't be a Tetra Karma.
Right. Okay. So, and, uh, when we
tried the exact same tests with him,
I mean these three, they look the
same, don't they? To, you know,
I see different, he was amazing. Uh,
every time the first one on the last
few jumped out immediately, number one,
they all three look different to me.
Wow. Was he just as good as Susan? Yeah,
I always a little bit disappointed.
I gotta say it was no where,
where he couldn't do it and
she could no better than me.
I only had pieces of brown cloth, you
know, so it doesn't prove anything.
I guess she still might be a tetra
Chromat. Right. For All I know.
And there was this one moment I
had no, it doesn't prove anything,
but I asked her, um,
I asked her about the sky and the sky
was just that quintessential sky blue and
she was, I was like, what
do you see? And she's like,
see, um, do you see some of
the pink and the blue? See,
I see a lot of pink. Like among the blue,
there's red in that blue section,
she was looking up at a blue sky.
And seeing red. Yeah. Yeah.
Do you see that? No. Oh,
I see so much red like up here and it's,
uh, it's kind of a cop out, but it's
just kind of that perfect sky blue.
Okay. That's, that's a good,
it's just mixed in there.
That's cool. I think I don't see is any
green in that blue? I just see reds,
right? Especially around
the white clouded section.
And at that moment I felt
like my sky is boring.
I'm so sorry for you.
For us. I'm sorry for us.
No, I mean, how do we know
that any of this makes sense?
Yeah, that's the fine of it. Yeah.
So
[inaudible] as a minutes. Hold is
that phase at first just goes to
the Tony Shayda. Hey,
Brown's browns, man about me.
Joe's mad.
She's just mad about me calling him.
[inaudible]
you know, we haven't talked
about yet. What's that? Um,
where do the colors come from? Okay.
I mean like, like I'm sky colors. No,
no, like, like painterly colors.
Like, uh, like marine blue and, oh,
like artificial colors. Well, no,
they're not out. That's the thing.
You think they come from
a factory or something,
but originally they came
from the earth. Yeah.
And there's one story about Chloe that
has haunted me for about a year and a
half. It's so strange. I don't know
if it's true or not, but I mean,
I don't know if you've read my book
of good. That's Victoria Finley again.
Her book is called color. And
this story starts with, well,
a particular kind of goop. It's
a color called Gumbos. It's um,
it's named after Cambodia,
a French word for Cambodia and it comes
from the SAP of a tree that grows in the
Cambodia, Vietnam, Thailand border
area. And this is a yellow color.
It's a color
[inaudible].
How you get it is really
the sticky part. I mean,
the way they get it is that they cut a
slash in the bark and then hitch up a
tube made of bamboo about the
circumference of a quarter. Yes.
And then little droplets of goop come
on. A little tiny drop does a good,
and they fill up the tube
the same way you do. You know,
you get maple syrup or, or rubber,
but they leave it for a
couple of years. Years. Yes.
Aw.
All right. So it's a release
precious.
So slow drop.
That's some pretty strange thing. Draw up
[inaudible] can happen in that time.
What do you mean snap has secrets?
Secrets. What? Secrets. Wait a minute.
So after two long years,
the harvesters come back and each of
those tubes is now full of this. Um,
quite quite like plastic. It sort of,
it's got that sort of plastic
resonate kind of feel,
but that's just the beginning. The resin
makes this incredible transformation,
which we actually saw Sean and
I. Hello. Thanks to this guy.
My name is Charles
claimer. I'm a color man.
He owns creamers pigments in
Manhattan and he sells this Cambos.
It is an important yellow,
amazing when you use it
[inaudible] powdered and the
resin form because when you
have a look at it or to this year,
it's just like this and the
doll it creed Brown. Yeah.
You imagine like a, a ball
of earwax. I mean you think,
well that's not very interesting coming
out of Dusky sort of people are in
color, but then you put
a drop of water on it
or you grind it up in a bowl with a
little water in your on that it looks like
this blue. Let's see, and there it is.
What does a little bit of lips
bright, very bright yellows,
bright fluorescent yellow.
Suddenly it's like power.
It means it is quite an
excitedly color. Very, very loud.
I carried one around for ages so
I to have a look at this color,
look how boring it is now put a drop
of water in it showing kids and I was
really happy. I give them,
gave it to one kid who was,
you just said you light it and it was
only afterwards that I found out that it's
so dangerous. I mean I use
dangerous. Why? Through get to bed.
Yeah.
When the guys used to chip it in in
small pieces was actually a time built in
from the visit the toilet
at least once an hour.
Ian Garrett knows that because he was
technical director at this art supply
company called Windsor and Newton in
England and here's what really got us
interested in all this.
Back in the 1980s Winsor and Newton
would get these shipments of Cambos from
Cambodia and they would take it
to them to this production room.
Quite a dusty area. Just
had a table in there,
big old table where the workers would
set and then they would have this hammer,
put the Cambos pieces on this
lump of iron and then hit it,
shatter it into small pieces because
that's how they make it into a kind of
usable, solvable paint.
And one day one of the workers was
chipping and scraping at the resin.
There they were, they found something
in the resin that they didn't expect.
They found bullets,
bullets in the hunks of
resin lodged in them.
Yet sometime in the two year
drip drip process toward the end,
probably as the resume was getting
thick, a bullet went through the air,
went into the goop and
stayed there. Actually,
it wasn't just one bullet total of about
a dozen and those are just the ones he
found lying around the factory.
There were probably many more.
They fall into two salts.
That's a very sharp pointed one about
just over an inch long and then the other
type A, a small sort of barrel shapes,
which are about three quarters of an
inch long and half a dozen of each.
How they got there and what they pass
through on the way into The Gambia,
I'm not sure
[inaudible].
Well,
we do know of course was that those
years in Cambodia where years of war and
murder, a million and a
half people died there.
Most of them in the killing fields and
that's the same place where you'd find
the gangbusters. I mean it's
shocking really any cause it,
those were just the random little
bamboo tubes hanging on the trees.
What happened in that grove?
The proposition here would
be that at some point,
maybe because of the famous killing fields
that some 14 year olds with collision
of cough rifles after finishing a
series of murders or just shot lots of
bullets, just sprayed that growth.
In order to get into the little tiny
bamboo canisters collecting this gunboat,
they would've had to have sprayed that
entire grove with machine machine gun
bullets. And in that year
or two years, um, somebody,
um, the ditch people I should think.
Yeah. Well, I mean, they, they, it's
not necessarily a battle scenario.
It could have been target practice.
You see these things hanging on
the side of a tree. You, you,
you want to practice your a marksmanship.
But th I mean, there is a way in which
the, there's violence in this color.
I guess. There's fine. It makes me wonder
about, does it ever give you pause?
[inaudible]
did they ever give me what,
sorry. Pause. Pause. No. Uh,
not really.
We would to remote bought it from a
guy in Holland who bought it from an
exporter who got it from
Lord knows where in Cambodia.
But the idea that it could've
been attached to to that.
Wow.
Bloodshed. Does that bother
you at all? You're saying them?
Do I think it's, it's morally acceptable.
Is that what you're asking me? Yeah.
Um, no. It wasn't Winsor Newton
who discovered these things?
These things were demanded by customers.
You're a hard-hearted man. I feel
I had never thought about it until
you, you pitched it like that.
As we kept on talking, Ian made it clear.
It wasn't that he hadn't thought
about the violence per se. It's just,
it wasn't like breaking news to him.
They sell some pigments that come straight
out of hills that are right in the
middle of war zones. Okay. Colors
are sometimes soaked in blood.
That's just how it is.
On the other side of the coin,
I've made it my career in 40 years to
make artists' paints on the basis that
people who paint tend not to make war.
It's a peaceful occupation
that is more or less what the Euston
George Kramer who runs the paint shop,
he was pretty much of the same mind.
You could think of it this way.
Imagine the first person to
ever find this brilliant yellow,
maybe 10,000 years ago.
He's walking through the forest after
it's rained and he sees it there on a tree
and he's amazed.
So he puts his finger into the yellow and
then Dab some on his face and he feels
instantly beautiful,
like larger than himself.
It is about being to something
transcendent and that just George is the
other side of the coin to an upper high
or whatever. Therefore,
[inaudible] from all sorts of
ceremonies, marriages, feasts,
maybe warpaint to feel invincible any
moment he suspects that needed to be
pulled out of the ordinary and lifted up.
And you need something that is prior to
something which is beautiful and special
and this yellow gives
her something special.
[inaudible]
it is perfect in all
[inaudible].
Thank you to Victoria Findlay. Her
book is called color, short and simple.
When to Ian Garrett, um,
of Windsor and Newton who did not wither
under our withering moral attack on
contrary.